- Oh my gosh, this is
such a difficult question,
because like...
- Oh, I'm getting emotional. (laughs)
Yeah, it's hard.
(emotional music)
I feel like loneliness
is really hard for me
'cause I'm constantly
surrounded by people.
But at the same time, when
I see people connecting
and understanding each other,
that's when I feel lonely.
Is when I feel like I don't have anybody
that understands me in that depth.
Oh, I'm getting emotional. (laughs)
But I feel like that's when I feel lonely,
is when I see people
connecting on a deep level,
when they don't have to say things.
You just have that person
that understands you.
- [Thoraya] You feel like you don't
have anyone like that?
- Yeah, no I don't.
And it sucks that I'm such a romantic,
but I think loneliness for me,
it comes from love, you know.
Like loving somebody and
not having them there.
Like that's so lonely.
And knowing that they're
living their lives.
Yeah, it's hard.
(audio cuts) That guy.
I'm just kidding, I'm just kidding.
- When I was a child
my mother was not able to
take care of our family
and I was put into a
receiving home for children.
So, probably then would probably be
the ultimate one that sticks in my head.
- [Thoraya] How old were you?
- I was eight, eight years old.
- I had a person in my life
who passed away very violently
and I couldn't talk
about it for a long time.
And that made me feel really lonely
because there was a lot of shame
and guilt that came with that.
'Cause he killed himself
and somebody else.
But the loneliness of that feeling
and knowing that no one
else could understand
was extremely isolating and
definitely really lonely.
- The loneliest time I've ever been
was when I had to live
in Saint Vincent de Paul
over at 12th and Imperial,
pretty much for four years.
And they're just homeless shelters
for family and certain individuals
and I lived there for about four years.
- [Thoraya] So, you were
homeless for four years?
- It's hard to explain how you don't feel
like you're connected to the community.
You're no longer part of
the whole world anymore.
You feel so left out in that space.
It's so much emptiness where you feel like
even interacting with
people is really hard
to even just say simple things like this.
- Pretty much just always lonely.
But not in a bad way, just keep to myself
and always alone, but it's fine by me.
- [Thoraya] So, you
kind of prefer your life
to be that way, sounds like?
- I mean it's like parallel
me wanting it to be that way
and just how it falls.
It just works out, I guess,
or maybe I'm just used to it.
- It's like which one do I pick?
So, you know.
I would say recent years,
the most loneliest time
I felt was coming out to
my family as being bisexual
and having that talk and
losing friends on the way.
It's the whole, I went
through the whole phase of,
"It's like an infection or something.
Don't tell your little brother,
he might turn out the
same way" kind of thing.
So, it's like, "You know that's not true."
It's like an old coming
out story in a sense.
At least I'm not the 50 year old guy
that's barely three divorces in.
I finally feeling like I've
taken a hold of my life.
You know, doing it now.
- My husband died not too long ago,
so I've never lived by myself.
So, and it's lonely.
Gonna be four years now.
But it's still lonely.
- [Thoraya] What's the
loneliest you've ever felt?
- Oh, man.
- I don't remember the
loneliest I've ever felt.
- [Child] You could just say it.
- Me getting divorced.
That's the loneliest I've ever felt.
- [Child] That is true.
(everyone laughing)
- Other than that, I don't
remember any other time.
- [Thoraya] So, can you explain to us why
that was such a lonely time?
- I don't know, it just
felt empty that day.
The day itself felt empty and weird,
but that's probably the loneliest.
I don't feel lonely ever since then.
- [Thoraya] Is this your son?
- My grandson.
- [Thoraya] Your grandson.
That's why what?
- That's why I don't feel
lonely 'cause I have him.
- When I was seven and
my mom went to rehab
and so, that was like the first
time I really felt lonely.
Because it was my first day of school
and all the other parents
were with their kids
taking them on their first day of school.
And then I only have my dad
and they all had their dads and moms, so.
- At least like the
loneliest feeling to me
would probably be the feeling,
not that no one's around
but just no matter who you
try to explain something to,
that nobody will understand
what you're saying.
- When was the loneliest I've ever felt?
Would probably be about two years ago
when I lost someone really close to me.
What happened?
Pretty much, he was
going through a hard time
and he did want me to be in a relationship
that I did not want to
be in but I did it anyway
and ended up losing all of my friends
and he ended up killing himself
and I stopped reaching out to people
because nobody was all like...
Everyone stopped being my
friend while I was with him.
So, I didn't really
have anyone after that.
Yeah.
- [Thoraya] Did he commit suicide
while you guys were in a
relationship together or after?
- It was after I ended it.
- The loneliest I've ever
felt was when I was 15
and I was in high school and
I had literally no friends
and people always made fun of me.
That's probably the loneliness.
- I usually just feel lonely
around the summertime.
'Cause I'm not very good at
asking people to hang out
especially during COVID time.
'Cause I've just sort of
been staying on the computer,
doing nothing.
So, that's about the loneliness I feel.
- That was definitely sophomore year
when I was in high school,
I am in college now.
So, I was always in class,
always the last person to be
chosen on the table groups,
always the last person to be chosen
when there was any ever,
like a group project.
And it was horrible.
I use art as my coping mechanism.
I would just be that sad kid in the corner
drawing all my art projects
and no one ever wanted to come up to me
and I didn't want to go up to them
because I just didn't feel
connected to any of them.
If I could describe it in
one word, it would be lonely.
- I grew up without a proper family.
So, I've always felt lonely.
I always feel like I'm
alone in everything.
- I was pregnant with my last baby
and I went through something
called antenatal depression.
It was really lonely
where you just kind of...
It's like postpartum, but
before the baby's born.
So, it was really hard.
I just feel alone and super sad
and you just don't know why
but it's really just your
hormones working against you.
That was a really tough question.
- [Thoraya] I'm so sorry.
Is it okay that you're talking about it?
Are you okay with that?
- No, I'm fine.
- [Thoraya] Do you feel better now
or do you still feel it sometimes?
- I think after kids,
everything always changes.
Your body, your hormones,
everything is different.
It does change you.
So, I do still suffer with
depression and anxiety
but I also have trauma from
my past and when I was a kid
so that might not help.
But that was like my loneliest time.
Even though I had great
family, great support,
I just still felt empty
and it was really sad
because I was carrying a
life and I knew he felt it.
So, it was like a really hard
and traumatizing experience.
- [Thoraya] If someone's
going through it right now,
what would you tell them to
help them get through it?
- Take time to do things
that make you happy.
It's so important. It's
okay to feel alone.
But the point is to not just stay in that,
you have to get out.
Cry, talk to people that love you
and just make sure you get up every day,
get up every day, open your windows,
open your windows bring in that light.
Just give yourself more positive
'cause it'll really drag you.
People don't understand
pregnancy and women's hormones
but you are not alone, we are all here.
People see you.
(emotional music)
- Hey, everyone, before you go
there's something I
want to share with you.
So, you'll notice today
that there's a join button
next to the subscribe button
on my YouTube channel.
And I just wanted to explain to you
why I decided to put that there.
So, I have a pretty crazy dream
where I'm hoping I can raise enough money
to go all around the world and film
in as many cities as possible,
and as uncomfortable as I feel
putting this join button on my channel,
I think and I'm hoping
that maybe it's okay
because one of the biggest requests
from you all on my channel is
for me to film in new cities.
So, now I'll explain to you all
what the join button means exactly.
When you go on my YouTube channel
you'll notice that right
next to the subscribe button,
there is a join button.
Just to let you guys know,
the join button doesn't alter
your subscription to my channel at all.
You can still be subscribed to my channel
and not join the membership.
The join button is just
an additional thing
if you choose to do it
and if you don't do it,
that's totally fine, honestly.
So, when you click the join button
you'll see a page with three
different membership options
that I've put together.
And depending on which one
you choose to sign up for
I offer you something in return.
And if you do decide to sign up for one,
honestly, thank you from
the bottom of my heart.
And if you don't sign up for
one, that's totally fine too.
You all do enough for me as it is.
That's pretty much it. Thank
you guys for everything.
I love you all and I'll see you next time.